so we have g of x being defined as the
log of 3x when
0 is less than x is less than 3
and 4 minus x times the log of 9
when x is greater than or equal to three
so based on this definition of g of x we
wanna find the limit of g of x as x
approaches three and once again this
three is right at the interface between
these two clauses or these two cases we
go to this first case when x is between
0 and 3 when it's greater than 0 and
less than 3 and then at 3 we hit this
case so in order to find the limit we
want to find the limit from the left
hand side which will have us dealing
with this situation because if we're
less than three we're in this clause
and we also want to find the limit from
the right-hand side which would put us
in this clause right over here and then
if both of those limits exist and if
they are the same then that is going to
be the limit of this so let's do that
so let me first go from the left-hand
side so the limit as x approaches 3 from
values less than 3. so we're going to
approach from the left
of g of x
well this is equivalent to saying this
is the limit
as x approaches 3 from the negative side
when x is when x is less than 3 which is
what's happening here we're approaching
3 from the left we're in this clause
right over here so we're going to be
operating right over there that is what
g of x is when we are less than 3.
so
log of
3x
and since this
since this function right over here is
defined and continuous over the interval
we care about it's defining continuous
for all x is greater than 0 well we can
just substitute 3 in here to see what it
would be approaching so this would be
this would be equal log of
log of 3 times 3 or
logarithm of 9. and once again when
people just write log here without
writing the base it's implied that we're
dealing
that it is
10 right over here so this is log base
10.
that's just a good thing to know that
sometimes gets gets missed a little bit
all right now let's think about the
other case let's think about the
situation where we are approaching 3
from the right hand side from values
greater than 3.
well we are now going to be in this
scenario right over there
so this is going to be equal to the
limit as x approaches 3 from the
positive direction from the right hand
side of well g of x is in this clause
when we are greater than 3 so 4
minus x
times log of 9. and this looks like a
some type of a logarithm expression at
first until you realize that log of 9 is
just a constant log base 10 of 9 is
going to be some number
close to 1.
this is just this expression would
actually define a line for x greater
than or equal to 3 g of x is just a line
even though it looks a little bit
complicated and so this is actually
defined for all real numbers and so it's
it's and it's also cont it's continuous
for any x that you put into it so to
find this limit to think about what is
this expression approaching as we
approach
3 from the positive direction well we
can just evaluate it at 3. so it's going
to be 4 minus 3 times log of 9 well
that's just 1 so that's equal to log
base 10
of 9.
so the limit from the left equals the
limit from the right they're both log
nine so the answer here is
log
of
nine
and we are done